Yeah,
good evening and welcome to the Lange
focus channel.
This is a quick video to bring you some
breaking news from the linguistic world.
According to recently released
documents,
the European Union will soon be adopting
Esperanto as an official language for
those who don't know,
Esperanto is a constructed language that
was created in the 18 slash 17 by Dr ll
Zimmerman Hoff.
It was created in order to function as
an international auxiliary language that
people all around the world can learn
and it was intentionally designed to be
extremely easy to learn,
but Esperanto never fully caught on and
remained mostly a hobby for language
nerds.
Until now.
According to EU officials,
Esperanto will be designated the 25th
official language of the European Union
and will function as a working language
of the European Parliament as well as a
procedural language of the European
Commission in addition to English,
French,
and German.
The EU is also expected to soon
recommend that all member states begin
drafting plans for public school
educational programs in Esperanto.
The unofficial word on the street is
that with the coming departure of the
UK,
from the European Union,
enthusiasm for learning English is
declining and Esperanto is a viable
longterm option to replace English as
the international language.
This new European Union policy will
begin on April 30,
first 2017.
This is wonderful news for Esperanto
lovers all around the world.
The Esperanza,
this dream of uniting the world with one
language is one step closer.
Please leave your comments in support of
Esperanza in the comment section down
below and show your support for this
European Union initiative.
Thank you for tuning in for this
important breaking news lang focus.
We'll be back with a regular video very
soon.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.